Speaker 1: I have for you,
I guess what I would call
a MAGA meltdown. But it's a MAGA pastor. Okay.
Giving is a Shane Vaughn giving a speech or a
sermon or a remark or whatever you want to
call it, about Trump and why his followers,
his viewers should support Trump
within the context of their religion.
And. What we're seeing here, Liz, and this is
not anti Christianity, anti religion at all.
This is look at the way he's bending his religion
to support his cult. It's very, very concerning.
Speaker 4: You are the 12 disciples that
God is called to stand behind Donald Trump.
And if Satan can get you tired. Donald Trump
loses because he cannot do this without you.
And they know that. So that's why every day
drama, trauma. And then here's what coward say.
I'm tired of all the drama. It's not drama. It's
spiritual warfare. Learn the difference. Carnal
minded people think it's drama with the enemy is
a tactic and you are defending your territory like
Donald Trump is. That's not drama. That is
spiritual warfare for the nation of America.
It's not pretty. It's not fun. It's not clean.
But somebody has got to do it. Call me somebody.
Somebody's got to do it. Raw 24.
I have made up my mind. I'm more
determined now than I've ever been to
stand behind this president. I'm more
determined now to stand behind the anointed.
I don't agree with everything the man does,
but I do agree with everything that God does.
And if God's okay with the man, I'm ready to
join hands with every one of you.
Speaker 1: I need some proof
that God's okay with Trump, sir.
Speaker 4: And saying, like the old
black churches used to say. I'm not tired yet.
Speaker 1: So let's just set aside that in part
and try to understand. I'm laughing and
it's kind of that you laugh so you don't
cry situation because a lot of people are
bought into this. And I know this anecdotally
and we understand this and the amount of
people who are hard core behind Trump and
how that intermingled with their
or intertwines with their faith.
And so often when I talk to people about this,
it doesn't to me seem like. And again, it's your
belief system. Of course, that's completely up
to you, but it doesn't seem like you're actually
trying to drive your political beliefs with with
something like this, with your faith. It seems
like you really want to love Trump. And so then
you're kind of figuring out how to say, well,
whatever is going on, I know for sure that
God loves Trump, so I have to love Trump.
But don't exactly explain why God has chosen
Trump as the anointed One as he said there. And
when I watch that, I just feel like I'm watching a
documentary about a cult, about the Trump cult 50
years from now. How wild was that Trump called?
It really is a historical event. At one point,
he said. You are the 12 disciples that God
is called to stand behind Donald Trump.
Yikes. And so what is so concerning about this
is. In politics, it can get pretty heated and you
can disagree a lot. But at the end of the day, if
you're able to sit down at a table, lay the facts
on the table, and then disagree about solutions,
disagree about minor things. Oh, I thought this
was the study that best represents the data. And I
thought that is all perfectly within a reasonable
political system. And still with people agreeing
on basic facts, you'll still fall very differently
on different political views 100%. What we've
gotten to now is individuals like the Shane Von.
Make it to where the ideology is such a circle and
it is such a, you know, an impossible situation
to get pulled out of that. We can't sit down and
talk about facts. I can't even sit down and try to
explain to you why I think Trump might be against
the Bible, because you can trump that all. No pun
intended by saying, does it matter? I know for
sure that God has anointed Trump. And so it really
makes it deeply impossible to get somebody out
of that cult. And that is what is so concerning
about this, and it's why we have to continue to
talk about it and raise awareness and hopefully.
By some miracle, pull some people out of it. But I
can tell you one thing. It's not going to be. Sir,
Pastor Shane Vaughan, thank you all for
watching today's show. If you enjoyed me
hosting, go over to Luke Beasley on YouTube.
Check out my show, The Luke Beasley Show,
and make sure you subscribe there and to The David
Pakman Show here on YouTube. We will see you soon.